bonsoir ça me fait sourire d'être là
devant vous pour vous parler de destine
de soi d'optimisme alors que je ne suis
pas toujours un modèle en la matière
mais si la vie m'a appris une chose
c'est que la route est longue mais il ya
une route
j'ai mis des années avant de pouvoir
dire je suis une femme ces simples mots
étaient tout bonnement imprononçable
alors non pas que je n'étais pas une
femme que je me sois appelé victor dans
une prime jeunesse c'est juste que je ne
me reconnaissais pas dans la définition
que me donnait la société vous savez ces
injonctions qu'on reçoit quand on est
petit qu'elles viennent de l'école de la
famille des amis
tiens-toi droite sert les jambes parle
moins fort sans parler des autres
vous savez ces petites filles modèles
celle qui aime le rose les princesses
les bonbons qui joue sagement au papa et
à la maman
moi j'avais la coupe à la jeanne d'arc
et j'étais monté sur un moteur à
réaction
voilà je vous laisse imaginer une gamine
de cinq ans sur un moteur à réaction
donc non concrètement ces cadres ne
convenait pas du tout votre souci c'est
que ni vous ne trouvez pas votre place
en tant que sam
ça c'est ce qu'une fille m'a dit quand
j'avais 18 ans je me suis étranglé la
place de quoi n'importe quoi quand
j'étais déjà pas une fille alors une
femme faut dire qu'à l'époque mes amis
principalement des gars on m'appelait
mec
j'étais la bonne copine asexué qu'il est
conseiller sur leurs rangs carrés qui ai
rigolé à leurs blagues graveleuses
donc ma place de femme
malgré tout j'ai commencé à me poser des
questions c'est quoi une femme elle
ressemble à quoi la femme que j'aimerais
être la femme que je voulais être
je la voyais tous les matins pour aller
en cours talon bas couture
jeu criant démarche assurée chaloupés
bref la femme fatale
ma femme idéale j'ai toujours été plus
fasciné par les femmes séductrices forte
dominante que par les princesses en
détresse vers 11-12 ans quand une amie
m'a demandé alors c'est avait un super
pouvoir ça serait quoi j'ai répondu sans
hésiter que tous les garçons tombent
amoureux de moi au premier regard
alors qu'en quelques années plus tard
donc ursus littéraire m'a mis dans les
mains les liaisons dangereuses de
choderlos de laclos et le portrait de
dorian gray d'oscar wilde révélation
j'ai accédé à une notice détaillée sur
comment devenir la quintessence de la
femme fatale
une oeuvre d'art en soi alors si j'étais
toujours de gens non identifié aux yeux
des autres je comptais bien devenir la
femme avec un grand f
ma motivation
les gars ont bien sûr je me suis rendu
compte que le but de ma vie avait
toujours été d'être en couple de trouver
le bon alias le prince charmant
je vois qu'ils sourient dans la salle
qui aurait très bien de qui je veux
parler alors être la femme fatale pour
avoir tous les hommes à mes pieds oui
mais pour le prince charmant
j'étais prête à tout même endosser le
rôle de la princesse en détresse
une fois en couple mois la forte tête
indépendante
je devenais la parfaite petite femme
docile admirative devant son homme beau
et fort toujours d'accord
toujours compréhensive et tolérante même
pas jalouse
oui qui dit prince charmant dit femme
parfaite non alors quand ça se traduit
en soirée par regarde bien placé et
langoureux qui suggère je valorise sa
virilité au toit mâle alpha est dominant
viens viens enserré dans ce grand brun
musclé protecteur ou noir pauvre petite
chose fragile c'est redoutable ans
succès assuré par contre sur le long
terme une fois en couple est passé les
premiers jours disent ils avec l'homme
et de peur de le perdre
je finissais par me fondre dans l'autre
a glissé peu à peu dans un personnage de
sue mois transparents n'oubliant et où
je finissais fatalement par étouffer
mais je ne pouvais pas être moi même
dans parce qu'il aurait fallu que je
sache ce qu'ils étaient de 2 que
j'estime sa digne d'intérêt
et de trois quoi qu'il arrive je me
sentais bien trop vulnérable pour
risquer un roger delattre et mes
résultats je terminais asséché frustré
par faire payer à l'autre les barreaux
d'une cage que je m'étais construite
tout seul je pense que vous aurez saisi
qu'à l'époque niveau estime de soi
je n'étais pas vraiment vraiment au top
un c est tout et en plus il paraît que
quand on ne s'aime pas on ne sait pas
aimer
pire même ont fait du mal aux autres ce
fut une période de délicieuses
dégringolade isolement comportement
autodestructeur crise d'angoissé à
répétition médicaments
dépression mais heureusement j'ai une
bonne étoile assez musclé et une
thérapeute en béton armé qui je ne sais
comment a réussi à me faire avaler que
après les symptômes
il faudrait bien que je m'occupe des
causes c'est à dire de moi la route est
longue mais il ya une route et pour moi
elle a commencé dans un tourbillon de
plume de froufrous et de paillettes
quand en 2011 je découvre l'effeuillage
burlesque
j'avais toujours rêvé d'être une femme
fatale mais il n'y avait personne pour
m'expliquer toutes les créatures que je
croisais dans la rue semble m narguer
moi je détiens le secret
moi je sais faire ça avait l'air
tellement simple tellement naturel tout
ça n'a rien donné
ça s'apprend ça demande énormément
d'énergie de temps de travail et
d'argent aussi avec l'effeuillage
burlesque comprendre l'art subtil de se
déshabiller avec grâce et légèreté
j'apprends à marcher
j'apprends à me maquiller et à me
coiffer telle une diva des années 50
taleo robe à paillettes sophistication
élégance n'ont plus aucun secret pour
moi c'est pour la scène je le droit
alors sous couvert d'épanouissement
artistique j'enterre clair la chouineuse
complexé pour devenir lady salvia
salvia c'est mon nom de scène et pendant
quatre ans tout est proche ne m'ont plus
appelé que comme ça moi la pauvre petite
chose complexe est qu'ils étaient moins
que rien que les garçons appelés mec
j'allais devenir quelqu'un je devenais
quelqu'un je goûtais au pouvoir social
par le pouvoir de séduction le pied
aujourd'hui on me reconnaît dans la rue
mais on hésite à venir me parler
j'ai l'impression on me sollicite on me
demande
on me désire je finis la même pas
rencontrer le fameux prince charmant un
être exceptionnel avec qui je partage
trois ans de ma vie
alors tout va bien non pas du tout
dans l'intimité c'est toujours aussi
désastreux mon cher et tendre ne
comprends pas comment est-ce que la
séductrice à se firent mais avec qui il
a rencontré peut passer autant de temps
éplorée entre sa balance et son placard
et comment de l'autre côté le petit être
fragile et a pleuré avec qui il partage
sa vie n'a soudainement plus aucun
besoin de lui
une fois talons et perruques en filaire
le pouvoir a servi même le pouvoir de
séduction
à force de devenir salvia à la ville et
à la scène jeu finissaient par avoir
l'impression de ne plus pouvoir être
autrement
et si jamais et si jamais on se rend
compte qu'en fait je complexe qu'en fait
je suis vulnérables
caen fait sans lesquels je me sens à
poil et que non je ne dors pas en porte
jarretelles ni en chanel numéro 5
ça s'appelle le syndrome de l'imposteur
prisonniers entre une image de soi
faible et minable et un personnage écran
de super soit indestructible on se
retrouve alors avec une peur panique
viscérale et éreintante qu'un jour
quelqu'un donc des masques fasse éclater
la réalité au grand jour trouve la
faille
heureusement un jour quelqu'un m'a
trouvé cette faille
et devinez quoi le mans ne s'est pas
effondré aujourd'hui je suis là devant
vous et je peux vous dire je suis une
femme et je m'appelle claire
alors oui j'aurais pu venir vous parler
de comment devenir une femme fatale
mais après des années à voir est une
créature après quatre ans à être salvia
24 heures sur 24
j'ai fini par me rendre compte qu'en
fait je ne voulais pas du pouvoir mais
juste être bien faites moi j'aurai
finalement expérimenté au cours de ma
vie différentes stratégies pour essayer
de me remettre à l'égal de l'homme la
femme garçon manqué façon jeanne d'arc
qui rejette tout ce qui fait fille la
femme indépendante et carriéristes qui
nie tout semblant de sensiblerie en mode
moi je n'ai besoin de personne et enfin
la femme fatale tentant de reprendre le
pouvoir en jouant les mantes religieuses
croqueuse d'hommes
mais dans tous les cas je reste
effectivement là où il ya pouvoir il y a
des dominants et des vaincus et les deux
subissent messieurs n'avez vous jamais
entendu une fois dans votre vie cette
phrase aller là soit un mec un vrai le
pouvoir a servi des deux côtés alors non
messieurs je ne vous dirai pas
d'abandonner le pouvoir que la société
vous donnant ce serait trop facile
et non mesdames je ne vous dirai pas
qu'il faut cesser de s'indigner contre
le sexisme ordinaire
je crois que la réponse est ailleurs un
jour un couple de coach m'a dit que nous
avons tous au fond nous quelque chose de
pur quelque chose d'incassable
d'inaliénabilité bible qui c'est qui
nous sommes vraiment qui c'est ce dont
nous avons envie et besoin
ils appellent ça linder self le moi
profond
le centre c'est là que siège notre
puissance et si nous partions si nous
arrêtions de courir après le pouvoir qui
a servi et que nous partions plutôt
découvrir notre puissance
c'est tout simple ça peut commencer par
exemple demandez-vous suis vraiment en
train de faire quelque chose dont j'ai
envie
là maintenant ou quelque chose qui est
bon pour moi avec salvia je croyais
avoir trouvé mes réponses sans me rendre
compte qu'en fait je cherchais chez les
autres une reconnaissance que je
n'arrivais pas à me donner à moi même se
connecter à sa puissance c'est faire
tomber les masques
c'est apprendre à se connaître à
s'accepter
tu apprendras à lâcher prise sur nos
défauts et nos faiblesses et comprendre
que ça nourrit autant que le reste c'est
apprendre à s'aimer
parce qu'après tout cette histoire
d'amour là elles durent toute votre vie
cette démarche c'est celle que j'essaye
de transmettre aux femmes que
j'accompagne notamment lors d'ateliers
autour de la féminité pour apprendre les
codes et décortiqué jouer avec s'est
approprié pour s'en libérer alors à une
époque on ne sait plus vraiment dans
quel combat s'engager s'ils tentaient
quand on est encore l'espoir de changer
le monde
je crois que nous pouvons commencer par
nous mêmes apprendre à se connaître à
s'accepter à s'aimer et enfin devenir
capable d'aimer les autres mais de les
aimer vraiment hommes ou femmes en
couple ou nous pour des relations
authentiques
vrai et sincère nous pouvons être le
changement que nous voulons voir dans le
monde alors la route est longue mais il
ya nos hôtes et si nous entamons tous ce
soir ce voyage peut-être que la guerre
des sexes n'aura pas lieu
je vous souhaite donc bon voyage
merci beaucoup